what's up guys 7:00 coming to you from
London we are at Tower Bridge I want to
talk to you guys about my book and I
want some feedback so I'm launching a
new book it's going to be the top 10
rules of success I'm taking the 50 most
popular profiles that we've ever done on
the channel once I've had the most views
and I condensed them down so it's gonna
be a book that has two rules per page so
if we're looking at Richard Branson or
Mark Cuban or Oprah Winfrey or any of
the big entrepreneurs and celebrities
and people that we've profiled some of
those videos can be long you know some
realities can be 20 30 40 minutes and so
what I'm doing is taking it to two rules
per page so you can get through
everything super quickly and the ideas I
want it to be something that you look at
every morning and but not something that
you read all the way through read one
page this is my thought I want you to
read one page per day it's super easy to
read one page per day and then think
about it think about the lesson you just
learned and didn't try to find some way
to apply it to your life or to your
business the idea is if you read a page
a day and thought about you know these
great things that people are teaching
you it changes your environment it
changes your hopefully your morning
routine your structure what you think
about and what you surround yourself
with matters and so if you are on a
daily basis feeding yourself with ideas
from people who've accomplished some of
the greatest things in the world you
can't help but get greater yourself if
you are surrounded by people who have
big bold fashion ideas that they're off
making a huge change in the world you
can't help but be a little bit more bold
a little bit more courageous or selfless
so that was the idea behind making this
book behind the structure of reading one
page per day and so I want your feedback
what do you think about the idea any
thoughts suggestions that you have to
make it better the book is supposed to
come out December 6 that's at least my
goal it was December 6 and I launched my
last book and so
I thought and the anniversary of that
thing coming out your one word that I do
the second book so I'd love to get your
support on that one other thing that's
in the book as well is I took the ten
most common lessons that are in the book
so basically we have 50 entrepreneurs
ten rules each that's 500 different
rules and took the most popular ten that
came up over and over and over and over
and over again and that's something that
you guys have asked for a lot like what
are the most common rules what are the
ones that keep coming up and so the book
will actually lead with those ten most
common rules and then get into
entrepreneur at a time why not to run
over time with their top ten rules and
so I want your feedback what do you get
the idea
I want your suggestions how can I make
the book even more awesome than it is
I'm going to be hopefully soon getting
my test audience of thirty people in
Toronto to read through the actual book
and give me feedback this one is
actually gonna be self-published as
opposed to your one word that we want
with a major publisher so if you want to
get any answers to questions on the
self-publishing process let me know and
just looking forward to your thoughts
suggestions feedback and support I
really appreciate it and that's been on
my mind as I walked through who London
today so looking forward to hear what
you have to say leave it down the
comments below so thank you guys so much
for watching
I believe when you hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love
see you soon